wildly successful doing Arenas getting a
cocaine addiction selling out every
weekend on the road and Saturday he
defended his regular ship
with great ease ladies and gentlemen
sing it if you know the words this is
Hans Kim
[Music]
what's up chicks
just got back from Korea I finally did
what all those races have been telling
me to do for years and went back where I
came from
races make the best travel agents
they'll send you everywhere but
Mississippi and West Virginia
it's hard to be nice to people in Korea
because everyone looks the same
I'm like hey you look like the guy that
cut me off in traffic
and the guy that [__] my girlfriend
and my girlfriend
how am I supposed to respect someone
that looks like my girlfriend
foreign
I think uh you know it's really uh hard
to be back in America
um something that you might not know
about Korea is that uh I got my
girlfriend a t-shirt from Korea and a
lot of people might think that she's
doing some stolen kimchi because she's
wearing a Korea shirt and she's white
but I think she's had enough Korean come
in her for her to be an honorary member
if you take a DNA sample of her in the
right spot she's 100 Korean
all right thank you Hans Kim with a
great many punch lines many laps per
minute there I feel like there's a
little [__] fire underneath you
nowadays huh yeah a little some reason
I'm uh afraid for my life yeah all of a
sudden
all of a sudden we got Hans Wide Awake
it's funny because you were kind of off
a week on a week off a week on a week
but now that you know that you're
fighting for your job it appears as if
though we have you exactly at the type
of work you were doing when we first
made you a regular yeah it's crazy yeah
right before the cocaine addiction
yes Tony my eyes are wide open right now
wow no they're not they're not that is
incredible I believe that's what his
choke was Red Man
like that with the obvious truth
oh so let's talk about it Hans still
fresh back from Korea
I love it what else happened there that
uh we don't know about I try to have a
threesome with my girlfriend and what
else and uh a friend of hers and the bed
and uh she was uh I only had sex with my
girlfriend that night okay what did the
other girl do she was just sleeping oh
very creepy very creepy that's the
closest to a Bill Cosby joke you've ever
had before
incredible Ollie this is your first time
seeing Hans right what do you think
about this guy exciting
I've been to Korea I wasn't doing none
of that over there like
what's going on with you in your life
you're like what's going on
like okay my question like how did it
how did the threesome come up with your
girl were you just sitting there you was
like hey
that's a great question how do you pitch
a threesome to a girl like that I was
like hey let's just go to my house let's
all crash there it's like oh but you
only have one bed I'm like oh well it's
not a big deal I just try not to talk
about it
it's not a big deal
I thought if I [__] her good enough
her friend would be like oh what's that
did you feel like you were [__] or
good enough to wake her up I did not do
as well as I wanted to do
can you explain to us what you mean when
you say you didn't do as good as you
wanted to was it quick was it short
pumps I was just tired falling asleep
fingering her and uh wait
wait is that how it works when you have
an Asian penis you also have to finger
them like
throw double guns up you know what I
mean
I like to warm her up a little bit
oh okay the motor started uh the motor
started oh yeah was she sleeping also
yeah sort of
incredible so of course the other girl
didn't wake up you were falling asleep
okay just give you some help just give
you some help
how many guys in here have ever thought
this that if I'm knocking one girl down
in the room and another girl see it
that [__] go for it too how many guys
have thought that in this room
a lot of people be on your same page
like
[Laughter]
here what's going on over here
Hans that was a great minute I'm telling
you it seems as though we've got you in
a Prime fighting shape once again uh so
I mean I'm gonna send you uh off to the
back and then we'll bring you back out
after the next comedian said because
you're fighting for regular [__] again
everybody yeah thank you yeah for those
of you that
Saturday you man
[Music]
you might re-energize his uh work ethic
in his career where now every single
week he has to defend his regular ship
against one of the highest qualifying
candidates on Saturday night I gotta
give him all the credit in the world he
smashed the unbelievably likable
unbelievably talented five-year golden
ticket winner Enrique Chacon with
Grady's this week I think is an even
bigger challenge uh
ladies and gentlemen
if he wins he becomes a regular on kill
Tony he's from Toronto Canada everybody
he is
very very special in a great many ways I
believe it's called globally
globally challenged I was using a
different word on Saturday during the
uncensored screen brought to you by
moment house
[Music]
um ladies and gentlemen one of our
favorites of all time golden ticket
winner
fighting to become a regular this is a
brand new minute from the one and only
Jared Nathan everyone
oh [__]
here we go
oh my God
[Music]
[Applause]
for myself speech therapy
has involved
over the years it first started with me
saying tongue twisters
how much wood can a woodchuck chuck if a
woodchuck can chuck wood
now it evolved to me any
[__]
[Applause]
I dated
[Music]
[Laughter]
and
shoo after I went down there and said
her name
[Music]
is save them money
you know what they say magical stutter
there is no other thank you
Jared Nathan in a historical moment in
the show's history
[Music]
hahaha
shared an incredible uh another
incredible performance not quite as many
uh laps per minute as Hans but uh a
couple bigger like big Pops at uh at
different points different points uh
very fun how do you feel like that went
he went fantastic okay I think I was on
it you what I think
I think it was one of my best sets here
at the mothership okay I think for
myself
all right yeah I disagree with you yeah
I think I disagree too all right I see
what you're trying to do though you're
trying to get into the boaters heads
trying to pull some Joe Biden trickery
right now
oh the cost of bananas is uh down 10
after I raised it 60 uh two months ago
oh you guys are Biden fans okay we lost
you there no yeah there's a lot of
people visiting from California today
everybody oh welcome dear visitors we
don't have any fun when you're not here
okay so uh
Jared look at the look of seriousness
throw on your face oh my goodness this
is a big deal yeah it is so how do you
feel is that true that you've been
eating [__]
wow oh my God
[Music]
one of the great things about this show
is that when people like you are on this
show I get to look directly at the
guest's reaction
and this is Ali sadiq's first time
hearing of a Jared Nathan seeing a Jared
Nathan and listening to a Jared Nathan
Ali siddique you can say whatever you
want uh
what do you think about Jared oh my
goodness
that was your best set on the Mothership
second second or third maybe okay it was
it was
it was exciting
when you come out with the wrestling
thing you know
Joe came clear this time you're right it
came clearer than other times
it came clear this time for myself
[Music]
that is incredible I can't imagine if
this was my first time seeing you and
yeah like oh I want to see something
what you want to see something I'm here
I do not stutter
when he whispers he does not stutter
wow
don't worry it's not Airborne you can't
catch it
if I get through something on me
where do you see my jokes
all right let's get Hans Kim back out
here ladies and gentlemen
oh my goodness
wow I mean here we go ladies and
gentlemen Hans Kim for two years and by
the way this thing that we've done
tonight and on Saturday with Hans is the
only time we've ever done anything like
this uh it is absolutely incredible I
figure it is an absolute win-win
situation it goes to show you exactly
what the live audience is feeling
because I let you guys decide
so ladies and gentlemen how many of you
have Jared Nathan winning tonight's
regular ship battle Make some noise for
Jared
[Music]
all right
you've known him for two years you've
seen him over a hundred times on the
show how many of you think Hans Kim
retains again huh
I had a feeling the boy is in fighting
shape he's wide awake stronger than ever
Hans Kim how do you feel I feel great is
that oh that was perfect
still trying to [__] you up
try to hug him
you got any more fat retards for me to
beat Tony
wow
[Music]
well
than that
because next week you will be challenged
again and your opponent who has a lot of
confidence about the issue goes by the
name of Uncle laser everybody so I never
give away what's happening a week away
but we're going to do it Uncle laser who
hasn't been on this show in months who's
been out doing spots running longer sets
started on this show and he thinks he
has you but I'll tell you this Jared
thought he was gonna do it and I talked
to Enrique Chacon before the show on
Saturday and he thought he was gonna do
it I think it's an exciting way to
[__] kick off a show with a couple
Comedians and I think you should be
really proud of your work right now Hans
two years into writing a new minute
every week thank you guys it's great to
see you're reinvigorated take that mic
stand put it back on that pink X come on
guys make some [__] noise for Jared
Nathan and Hans Kim everybody
[Applause]
that was
that was that was on scam all right